[Music]
this was a moment for the people of
plymouth to come together
and pay their respects to those who lost
their lives in thursday evening's gun
attack
the lord mayor had asked people across
the country to stand with them in
solidarity
i hope and believe that we will get
through the difficult times that lie
ahead
as we try to come to terms with this
dreadful loss by continuing to support
each other
from downing street the prime minister
observed the minutes silence
so too the leader of the opposition keir
starmer
as plymouth continues to grieve the
community has raised more than 25 000
pounds for a local child bereavement
charity that has a very special way of
helping youngsters to cope
spoke to some
to a boy of about eight he was
struggling to get out of the house and
worried about that um and
i'd get my friend here i had
jeremiah gave him a jeremiah bear and
we were talking about if he's feeling
sad if he's feeling confused
give jeremiah a hug
last thing at night if he's lying in bed
worried
wispy whispier worries to jeremiah let
him take care of that and then you go to
sleep calm
the gunman jake davidson had been a
prolific user of social media
police forces assessing applications for
gun permits will now be required to
carry out checks on applicants online
posts
questions persist as to why the gunman
had his firearms license given back to
him by police last month when it had
previously been taken away following an
allegation of assault
the bishop of plymouth will lead a vigil
in the city in memory of the victims on
tuesday evening
ender brady sky news in plymouth